it's a wreck but at least in his car he
wonder for how long though especially
after a Hong Konger accused China of
torture earlier this summer
Simon Chung an employee of the British
Consulate here was detained by Chinese
authorities for two weeks without
explanation now in a detailed Facebook
post he has said that he was tortured he
wrote when the secret police took me out
of the detention center I was handcuffed
shackled blindfolded and hooded so it
was hard to breathe I was hung
handcuffed and shackled on a steep X
cross doing a spread eagle post for
hours after hours I was forced to keep
my hands up so blood cannot be pumped up
my arms it felt extremely painful we
believe that the claims that Simon was
made are credible and they amount to
mistreatment amounting to torture which
is a clear violation of international
law and under the UN Convention Against
Torture there is an obligation on China
which is a State Parties activation to
investigate and hold to account anyone
responsible for those kind of actions
China rejected that out of hand to
endear Beijing during his detention the
public security unit guaranteed all of
his rights and interests according to
law he also made a full confession about
his illegal actions the allegations came
just as Hong Kong had been recovering
the battle is over at Polytechnic
University it had been occupied by
thousands now there are only a handful
of protesters inside there either
determined to stay or too afraid to
leave this student is 17 years old he's
been here for five days now he asked us
to disguise his voice how do you feel
right now
the nervous and also hopeless yes I I
just want to go home now but I don't
want to get arrested or dead charged
because I'm afraid
listen he caught his father
my god and you are
in high tones your day what a woman the
super line so they continue to fight a
battle that's being tidied up outside
the cleanup operation is underway here
they've got a pretty big job on their
hands but this is the quietest we've
seen Hong Kong for the whole week really
question is whether that quiet will
remain in the wake of simon chance
allegations even if the holdouts did
have the will in some cases their bodies
have given up they're taken into the
care of the medics and the police tom
Cheshire Sky News Hong Kong